- All right, let's get to one last story.
I'm hoping we'll make you smile.
This is what I'm liking.
(bouncy music)
So most people dread going to the dentist.
It makes sense. It's not exactly
fun unless you get nitrous.
(crowd laughing)
Just saying.
Well, one North Carolina
Dental Hygienist is all about
making this experience less
distressing for people.
When the patients show up
she greets them in costume,
which is awesome.
- [Audience] Aw.
- For decades now, Judy's put
people in her chair at ease
and we have her on the line
right now watching on WXLV.
What's up, Judy?
(audience cheering)
- Hey Kelly.
- I love you so much. I love what you do.
So what made you start
doing this dressing up?
- Oh, back in the early
1990s, I had a patient
who gifted me with a leftover
New Year's Eve party hat.
I wore that hat that whole day.
I greeted my patients
with a "Happy New Year."
I couldn't believe the difference it made.
They actually smiled!
Who smiles coming to the dentist?
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
Anyway, since that time,
I have worn something
silly or fun every day
when I greet my patients and
bring them back to my room.
I usually take most of it off though
before I start cleaning their teeth.
(Kelly laughing)
- 'Cause it would be
funny if they were under
and then all of a sudden they came out
and they're like (screams and laughs).
It's funny video footage, just saying.
Tell us about some of
your favorite costumes.
- Well, just about anything
to make my patients feel comfortable,
calm, cool, even laughing.
I have a bunch of silly glasses.
(Kelly laughing)
I have funky hats.
I even have the full costumes.
Like the one-eyed, one-horn,
flying-purple-people tooth cleaner.
(Kelly laughing)
Or the super flosser girl.
Sometimes you do have to
be serious and that's okay.
But other times you can have fun and laugh
and joke with your patients.
And they even look forward
to coming to see me,
believe it or not.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
So anyway, just remember brush twice,
floss and have fun every day.
(audience clapping)
- Exactly, Judy. Oh my gosh, I love you.
You're making me miss home
with that accent, I love it.
Thank you so much, Judy.
(Judy laughing)
I'm liking your post right now.
(audience cheering and clapping)
And that's not all, Judy.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
and making people feel comfortable
and happy just like you.
So they're gonna give you $1,000 dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- That's great! That's
marvelous. Thank you.
- All right! Have a blessed
day, Judy. Thank you so much.
And thank you to all
of our guests this hour
(audience cheering and clapping)
Jake Gyllenhaal, Matt Iseman,
Daveed Diggs and Ian Munsick.
Y'all have a great day. If
it's not, try and change it.